Esse
[Aplausos]
é o olho a minha infância algumas vezes
eu não consigo acreditar na potência que
eu me tornei mulher favelada cria do
Morro da Providência hoje já com muito
orgulho disso
e eu passei parte da minha infância em
um casarão na central do Brasil
dividindo o único banheiro com 200
pessoas um emaranhado de gente uma
legítima a cabeça de porco e vem
Joãozinho de muita gente que eu não ia
ser ninguém na vida hoje eu tô aqui a
gravidez da minha mãe não foi desejada
pelo meu progenitor e ela grávida
sozinha com mais dois filhos Precisou se
esforçar Em um nível inenarrável para
que eu pudesse vir ao mundo e como se
isso não vai estar se ela sempre sofreu
de esquizofrenia é uma doença mental que
causa surtos e alucinações
e eu passei a minha infância entre o
casarão um sítio que ela tomou conta em
troca de moradia e o Morro da
Providência
aqui eu quero fazer um parente as
histórico que eu acho incrível um Morro
da Providência é a primeira favela do
Brasil surgiu em 1897
o ou seja o meu logo tem 124 anos a
providência fica no centro do Rio de
Janeiro ao lado da Central do Brasil
entre o santo Cristo EA Gamboa é um
lugar de muita história os primeiros a
chegarem lá foram lembro de do exército
que lutaram em Canudos no Sertão da
Bahia contra Antônio Conselheiro
vitoriosos Eles vieram para o rio em
busca da recompensa que foi Prometida
pelo governo a casa própria mas como a
gente sabe na história brasileira O
governo não cumpriu a promessa e ele sem
ter para onde ir ocupar uma Providência
mais ou menos na mesma época pessoas que
haviam sido escravizadas tão bem foram
se estabelecendo no morro que vocês
sabem né Mesmo depois de 300 Anos de
Escravidão a Lei Áurea e a sua falsa
Abolição em 1888 não proporcionou uma
moradia digna e nem remuneração para
aquelas pessoas e tem um ingrediente que
torna essa é muito importante antes de
ser Morro da Providência eles chamavam
Morro da Favela os soldados deram esse
nome porque favela é uma planta rasteira
muito comum em Canudos lá no Sertão da
Bahia e aí favela passou a terra o
sentido que vocês conhecem mas hoje a
gente luta para desconstruir a imagem de
que favela é sinônimo de coisas ruins
favela é potência resiliência e invenção
todo o resto gente a falta de política
pública
e quanta coisa né vocês não acham que
são motivos para me orgulhar Eu costumo
dizer que para trilharmos um caminho de
autoconhecimento
é preciso saber de onde a gente vem e
ter muito orgulho disso eu vim desse
lugar vem também de uma infância de
violência de baixíssima autoestima eu vi
as pessoas falando quanto a base
familiar era importante e que os
primeiros sete anos de vida eram
essenciais para decidir quem você é
eu só conseguia pensar que eu tava
lascada porque essa época da minha vida
foi terrível na pré-adolescência o meu
diiva eu não gostava do meu cabelo eu me
achava feia eu me achava magra eu
alisavam meu cabelo eu pintava que de
alguma forma eu achava que isso ia
tentar resolver o que eu tinha dentro de
mim não a juventude eu trabalhei com
tudo faxina telemarketing festa e por aí
vai quando eu estava prestes a completar
20 anos e um dia muito e eu cheguei no
meu trabalho Briguei com a minha
supervisora peguei e minha moça e sair
andando eu fiquei andando na cidade até
chegar no Largo da Carioca eu sentei ali
na praça e comecei a chorar eu chorei
muito
Oi e aí de repente olhei para o lado e
tinha um grupo de teatro se apresentando
ali eu fiquei hipnotizada e parei de
chorar
parecia cena de um filme Quando O
espetáculo acabou eu fui atrás dos
Artistas em cortejo até OS Arcos da Lapa
na casa do grupo
era a casa do ta na rua
e ali era o meu lugar eu fiquei com voar
durante oito anos um dia no meio da
praça Nos Arcos da Lapa numa roda cheio
de gente o diretor a minha que é o
diretor do grupo ele me apresentou ele
disse assim essa é Cíntia Santanas atriz
favelada da primeira favela do Brasil o
Morro da Providência
o
YouTube deve ter durado cinco segundos
mas para mim parecia uma eternidade
e finalmente eu tava sendo quem eu era
de verdade sem medo nenhum e o público a
gente o público me aplaudiu aquelas
pessoas me olhavam como quem reconhecia
que ali tinha uma menina que tinha se
encontrado de verdade eu tava muito
feliz aí eu descobri a auto estima
os sentimentos porque a palavra eu fui
descobrir depois eu comecei a perceber a
potência que tinha em mim o quanto eu
tinha para fazer e sonhar o quanto eu
era capaz com o tempo e com as plantas
com a galera do teatro eu fiz a
transição capilar Soltei o meu cabelo
comecei a gostar de mim e comecei a
parar de pensar o que que as pessoas iam
pensar se soubessem que eu morava na
favela e eu me entreguei o teatro e
Dionísio me abençoou por causa do teatro
eu andei pela primeira vez de avião eu
dormi Hotel eu tomei banho de banheira e
eu tomei aquele café da manhã a gente
ficar para nós aquilo ali parece uma
janta É desnecessário eu entrei para a
escola técnica de teatro Martins Penna a
mais antiga da América Latina eu tava
realizada
é mas tem uma coisa que me incomodava
quando eu voltava para mim a realidade
eu ficava pensando como é que pode ter
pessoas vivendo tão bem e pessoas
vivendo tão mal por causa dessa
inquietação eu decidi da aula de teatro
na favela eu achava importante que as
crianças tivessem acesso a tudo o que eu
tava tendo Enquanto elas eram crianças
porque eu já tava velha a primeira vez
que eu fui na aula de teatro na quadra
da Providência com alguns integrantes do
tá na rua gente chegou na quadra
descansavam jogando bola hoje não
queriam parar de jogar bola para gente
dar aula então a gente combinou que a
gente vai jogar meia hora de futebol com
elas para depois elas fazer penteado em
um determinado momento tudo era jogo
tudo era Thiago porque teatro é vida
porque o teatro tem esse poder de ser e
trocar ali eu decidi percebi que eu tava
fazendo a coisa certa mesmo sem saber
aonde aquele ia dar no final da escola
algum tempo depois eu queria me E o Enzo
céu e a favela que hoje atende quase 500
crianças e adolescentes e mulheres na
região da Providência lá tem curso de
teatro qualificação profissional
atendimento psicológico muita coisa
legal um projeto que só surgiu depois
que eu recuperei A Minha autoestima do
desejo que eu tinha de levar para essas
crianças para que elas pudessem sonhar e
alcançar os seus objetivos eu lembro que
eu coloquei uma vez seis crianças para
ensinar em um espetáculo com segurando
música e texto elas usavam o espaço da
favela o bar uma casa e a praça e por
onde elas iam passando elas iam
colorindo tudo porque o teatro ele tem
esse poder de ressignificar os espaços
principalmente ali onde a violência se
faz presente no dia a dia através do
teatro a gente pode ressignificar nossa
dor protestar falar quem somos E aí
talvez alcançar é a máxima no mundo e aí
você pode estar se perguntando nossa ela
criou uma ONG só por conta da autoestima
sim quando você nasce em um lugar que só
é possível sobreviver é impossível você
pensar em autoestima lá na favela sonhar
é um ato revolucionário
nesses nove anos que eu me dedico esse
trabalho eu percebi que não tem uma
receita exata para você ser feliz e
superar os desafios mas quando será
pobre favelado da certeza de uma única
oportunidade mas não adianta essa única
oportunidade se você não se sentir Capaz
se você não sentir que aquilo também
pertence a você
é a minha primeira oportunidade na vida
foi o Tiago foi naquele dia lá atrás que
eu tava chorando encontrei o grupo Tá na
rua aqueles artistas o contato com a
arte com o público me fizeram perceber
quem é o era de verdade por isso eu
quero convidar vocês a serem a primeira
oportunidade na vida de crianças que
vivem à margem da pobreza
crianças que precisam ter acesso à
educação alimentação dignidade e
principalmente ao acesso à saúde mental
ao reconhecimento da sua autoestima
Calma eu não tô dizendo para vocês
saírem por aí criando uma ONG vocês
também Pode claro Mas o que eu tô
dizendo para vocês ajudarem como puder
eu tô muito feliz porque eu comecei
primeiro a mudança em mim no lugar onde
eu nasci cresci e moro até hoje para
fechar eu quero oferecer esse momento
para minha mãe
e a mulher mais resiliente que eu já
conheci nesse mundo ela tá viva e tá
muito feliz que eu tivesse oportunidade
de falar para tanta gente e a 15 anos
ela não tem mais surtos
e eu quero deixar um beijo e lembre-se a
transformação ela é coletiva Qual é o
seu papel para que ela aconteça
E aí